à marseille au procès des profanateurs
du cimetière juif de carpentras l'avocat
général a demandé le maximum deux ans de
prison pour les deux skinheads qui n'ont
à aucun moment au cours du procès
déclaré regretter leurs actes en
revanche la peine a été légèrement
inférieure et 18 mois pour celui qui
s'est dénoncé et le quatrième qui a
montré quelques remords verdict le 24
avril prochain
dominique verdeilhan philippe chasselas
ce dossier est un échec policier
judiciaire le procureur fabienne roze
fait aveu d'impuissance
c'est un attentat qui a été commis à
carpentras et nous magistrats
nous n'étions pas préparés à cette forme
de terrorisme nous ne savions rien de
l'extrême droite et des mouvements
skinheads sans les aveux de garnier ce
procès n'aurait pas eu lieu
le magistrat s'interroge sur l'avenir
des quatre prévenus il va falloir les
gérer qui demain va vouloir les
embaucher la défense est contrainte à
rester profil bas elle plaide la
personnalité plus que le dossier pour
elle la réconciliation ne sera possible
que si le pardon réciproque
je pense qu'ils ont fait partie pendant
un temps du camp du diable et que nous
qui sommes dans le camp des hommes
nous devons cette humanité que nous
revendiquons l'a démontré qu' il ya sept
ans il y a même quatre jours pouvait
imaginer que le mot pardon serait
prononcée par madeleine germain a fait
dans mon cas c'est peut-être pas de leur
faute c'est face au vent une priorité
élevée et à l'éducation deux premiers
est ce qu'ils vont devenir ça vous
intéresse je prends pas ce que je vais
devenir moi je reste quand même être ma
douleur
ce soir les quatre profanateurs ont
rejoint les pommettes madeleine germes
on ne les reverra pas elle ne viendra
pas à marseille pour le jugement dans un
mois elle veut les oublier et ne plus
penser qu'à félix son mari